salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien alors je suis super content
de vous montrer ce documentaire que j'ai
réalisé pour brut et qu'il ya quelques
mois vous allez découvrir une histoire
qui m'a beaucoup touché que je voulais
vous raconter en fait je me suis
toujours demandé pourquoi certaines
personnes s'engager à 18 ou 20 ans dans
l'armée et qu'est-ce qu'il est motivé à
partir faire la guerre à l'autre bout du
monde pour une cause qui parfois
apparaît un peu lointaine alors j'ai
rencontré théo qui va répondre à toutes
ces questions le documentaire est en
fait je tourne avec lui au mali quelques
jours à peine après un événement super
traumatisant n'est pas du trois amis
là-bas sur place alors je tenais à vous
dire quand même que la situation au mali
a pas mal changé depuis un les forces
françaises sont en ce moment même en
train de partir du pays ce sont donc
quasiment les dernières images de
l'armée française là bas pour info sur
ma chaîne youtube je vous raconte les
coulisses de ce tournage je vous mets le
lien en descriptions en attendant je
vous laisse regarder le documentaire qui
s'appelle 28 décembre et on se retrouve
en fin de vidéo
[Musique]
attendez une minute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pensais pas que
j'étais touché aussi à ce point là
tutto dante faut que la population
français sachent que ce qu'on vit ici
c'est quand même
[Musique]
trois nouveaux soldats français morts en
opérations au mali trois jeunes soldats
qui était arrivé au mali il ya seulement
un mois
[Musique]
c'est un engin artisanal une mine de
tout simplement qui a qui a explosé sur
leur passage
nouvelle histoire tragique qui vient
endeuiller cette opération barkan c'est
environ 50 morts
[Musique]
c'est vrai que la vocation d'un soldat
c'est d'aller au combat mais
certainement pas de mourir à 20 ans
non non c'est bon
c'est bon je veux continuer
[Musique]
je suis le brigadier théo g 20 ans
au mois de mars va faire deux ans que
fait l'armée
quoi ouais
t'as qu'a pris aussitôt dans pas
longtemps un fait qui appuient abattoirs
[ __ ] art
oh
et de repos bonjour à tous j'espère vous
avez bien dormi
profitez de ce réveil un peu plus
naturel que d'habitude
je tiens à vous alerter
faut rester concentré jusqu'à la fin de
la mission la mission n'est pas terminée
messier ou
méfiez vous on est dans une zone dans un
territoire hostile où tout peut très
vite déraper
c'était un peu comme des grands frères
ils étaient tous plus vieux que moi
je les ai connus dès mon entrée à
l'escadron et au peloton
depuis je suis alarmé j'ai tout fait
avec eux
c'étaient des frères
pocher avait un an de plus que moi il
avait 21 ans issaka n'y en avait 24 et
le maréchal des logis mauri on avait 28
on était tous très proches surtout avec
les deux premières classes pocher
issakhanian
[Musique]
avec qui sait qu'anne et on était
collègues de chambre au régiment ont été
tout le temps ensemble
c'était des super gars né super gars
[Applaudissements]
le 28 décembre on était tous parti en
convoi
le aller s'est très bien passé et on a
réussi à y aller en 6 7 heures alors que
les autres précédemment avait avait fait
en 13 heures on est parti très tôt le
matin il y avait presque personne
c'était quasiment désert
c'était entre guillemets bizarre mais ce
ne sera pas tilté tout de suite
les trois quarts des véhicules passent
et on entend un bruit bizarre à la radio
grésillement
tout de suite on s'est retourné
puis on a vu en espèces de 2 grands
nuages une gros nuage de fumée avec une
grosse poussière noire et une boule de
feu et là on s'est dit ah non c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
des journaux oui
j'ai pas joué ici ça les cro bat qu'un
no to c c'est un dieu je suis allé au
bac
à la série marche à bestiaux oui mais
j'ai bon marché ça peut être ma chaise
saison nécessaire seat en attente parce
que des chiffres et des lettres
ok on va débuter leurs rôles pour la
mission demain c'est pas une balade
on fait très attention ce qui doit
éveiller notre attention les triporteurs
les suv et pick up i les motos ok faut
être très fins
d'affaires la situation générale dans la
ville de gossip est inchangé alpha
situation et demi ni globale qui
chercheraient à mener une ou des
attaques d' opportunité afin de gêner
notre action
y'a pas d'autres questions
ok j'en ai terminé demain matin
formation de la ram à 7h30 façade nord
contrôle radio à 7h45 bon après
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça de plus
petits au début c'était plus pour faire
l'histoire la guerre entre guillemets
comme dans les films
j'ai toujours été fasciné par
par l'armée depuis le plus jeune âge
j'ai eu un grand père qui était alarmé
aussi armée de l'air
mais lui il était contre l'armée mon
père ne voulait pas non plus
ils ont une mauvaise image de l'armée
comme si on envoyait les hommes au
casse-pipe tout le temps pour pas grand
chose quoi
de plus intégré l'armée je n'ai plus de
contact avec du côté paternel ça fait
beaucoup de vins de problèmes au sein de
la famille d'ailleurs
fa
oui ça va ça va ça ouais je n'étais pas
très bien j'avais un peu j'étais un
prêtre acquiert le choix il va bien
[Musique]
fait pour ta connerie
patron inquiète depuis l'action
sortir
ça c'est difficile
[Musique]
difficile
de faire appel demain normalement après
demain soir après la mission
au quai
au revoir
business
[Musique]
cashback chaque fois que je monte dedans
nul
je repense à tunis en
forcément mais france
immense
non
c
[Applaudissements]
et
il ya un espèce de contrôle radio qu'on
fait d'habitude et il ya vu une
patrouille qui n'a pas répondu
vu qu'on était de tête on arrivait très
vite à proximité du lieu de la zone de
l'incident
essayer de voir s'il y avait un
mouvement de vie savent aussi bouger
s'il était conscient et avait pas de
problème donc on s'était dit bah c'est
bon ils ont été amochés mais ils sont
encore en vie
avait ce jour là
je suis malade ouvrir au levain
qui a faim
quelqu'un qui vise à la première fois
ouest et 1
les gens ils réalisent un fait plus de
l'annoncé du
le métier dès qu'on n'est pas parce
qu'on tue pas pour théo lui détruit
jeune il profite pas de sa jeunesse il a
décidé de venir à l'armée c'est
peut-être pour que si la défaire ou des
soeurs ou des copains lui puis je veux
continuer à vivre normalement aller à
l'école faire leur vie normale sans se
soucier des problèmes qui peut arriver à
l'étranger
je pense que quand on est jeune on se
rend pas vraiment compte de
les sacrifices qu'on fait
pas en tout cas moi je m'en rends pas
vraiment
ne pas dire du tout je vends pas content
du tout n'a pas encore par balles puis
malheureusement là des fois il ya des
gens qui ne quitte plus tôt que prévu
on avoir les jeunes quand ils s'engagent
ils ont des consciences
ouais
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sergent
ça fait à peu près un an qu'on se
prépare bien avec plein d'exercices qui
nous met en situation
face eux à des forces adverses effective
bien sûr mais qui nous entraîne et sont
bien poussé
je suis assez serein repartir
les traits joue là vous sacrifiez
justement pour l'armée
après on verra oui certainement je suis
prêt après il faut voir en fonction de
du moment on n'est jamais forcément
prêts pour mourir bon on esquive un peu
parce qu'on a on a du mal à parler un
peu de la mort en étant jeune c'est
quelque chose de
fin ça nous paraît un peu irréel mais
joe
fcl votre téléphone vous avez filmé suis
pas votre téléphone
le téléphone téléphone tu es jeune tu la
cellule la salle toile est
notre identité aussi
[Musique]
m
et parce que ta tête tu peux jouer comme
ça
bah je dirais pas et c'est la peur mais
c'est un stress un
gros stress
et du mouvement partout
et d'un coup c'est très dur de prévoir
quelques uns qui déboule de nulle part
et
probablement et tu peux nous tirer
dessus
oui on les a menés dans les commentaires
mais c'était déjà il était déjà parti
sans qu on ait pu rien faire
justement directement sur le coup
c'était un moment très dur mais on était
content pour recueillir une belle
cérémonie
à leur égard
c'était la première fois que tu voyais
la mort
[Musique]
d'être confronté à la mort comme ça oui
c'était direct mais violent
c'est un peu nos trois étoiles qui nous
surveillent si nous protège
son jeu garde
sur le coup on n'a pas une envie de
vengeance un peu
sur le coup s'ils en ont envie de
de tout casser on a envie de choquer
le 1er mai qui passait lui mettre la
misère ça c'est
un sentiment qui a été longtemps en nous
mais faut quand même faire preuve de
deux jugements et d'être sûr que ce soit
un an et demi et que on ne fasse pas de
de dommages collatéraux
balancer un peu
le couple moteur
les identités
non
m
c'est là je t'écoute et là il est là
cette fois oui
juste la
bagnole
et est-ce qu'on est toujours le même la
presse a
forcément nom n'est pas le même on
change littéralement on prend puisque
conscience que la vie est quelque chose
de très précieux
on se rend compte que les petites choses
du quotidien
basse et c'est très important c'est
c'est quelque chose de
dinde incroyable
donc on change profondément déjà sur nos
divisions de vie
[Musique]
un jour
ça sent les gens voulaient leur maman il
y avait en fait d'avoir felipe massa
propos
ok c'est vraiment pas trop les filles
apprendront quatre coins
à bas c'est vraiment crème forcément
où il fait comment parler tous les soirs
il a tellement
d'accord
non pas ça qui va t'en
[Musique]
base ici charly 9 mise en place
effectuée et reste
on est bien
voilà je suis dans le charlie duke à la
c1 au tour de garde et non robin doit
surveiller l'extérieur
s'assurer que personne de suspect ne
dépassa digue
ça va
j'avais pour vous
et apparation ya rien pour toi
je peux pas partir non
oh
le cas cette année c'est tout noir
michael hall via vite fait les anglais
les chefs qui passe
et qui nous déclinons passe par la tête
on y pense ce
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à tant qu'innocent
crise nous passe par la tête
n'est qu'un oui on y pense
ni qu'un une lumière un truc
vous avez
un souvenir ou un truc comme ça fait mal
au crâne tout seul
[Musique]
récompense car moi rien et ça passe tout
seul
tous sont graves
c'est rien ça s'en va et ça revient ça
fait bizarre
[Musique]
et vous
oui forcément pas qu'on serait ce n'ont
pu emporter dans une spirale de
dépression et de tristesse sinon on
devrait plus a vu qu'on pense que tout
le temps a battu quand même continuer à
vivre pour eux à rigoler tout en pensant
en parlant en se rappelant des histoires
qu'on avait avec eux des situations
marrantes qu'on a pu connaître connaître
avec eux ensemble
c'est important toujours vous rigoler
ensemble
c'est ça permet de garder une transe
morale importante
à
petite île des bonbons force morale vous
avez vu un peu
ok je suis peut-être jeune doit
remplacer résilience résidence c'est ce
que c'est c'est l'opération un seul
acteur passif dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'espère que ce documentaire vous a plu
et surtout vous avez appris des choses
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à licques et à partager a
commenté si ça vous intéresse j'ai aussi
fait une vidéo coulisses sur ce tournage
sur ma chaîne youtube personnel je mets
le lien juste en descriptions dans cette
vidéo je vois qu'on a un petit peu ce
que théo est devenu depuis que je vais
filmer comment j'ai réussi à travailler
car mes française et je vous dirais un
petit peu plus aussi où en est la
situation au mali aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup d'adressé jusqu'à la fin de
cette vidéo et je vous dis à très
bientôt
[Musique]